from Teen Titans and the X-Men to Iron
Man and Batman the boy's most recent
casting announcement could have huge
implications for the inspiration of the
upcoming fourth season of the Amazon
Prime video superhero Series in addition
to confirming that Simon peggs Hugh
Campbell will return for season four the
show's Instagram also announced the
editions of Elliot knight from the DC
series Titans Supernatural Alum Rob
Benedict and prolific film and
television actor Rosemary DeWitt while
both Knight and Benedict's roles are
being kept under wraps for now DeWitt is
confirmed to be playing Huey's mother
first mentioned in the show's second
season Huey's mother mysteriously
abandoned him and his father when the
former was just six years old though
were likely a long way off from even a
mere trailer for season four of the boys
this casting announcement points toward
a few promising plot lines and possible
character introductions specifically for
the two unannounced rules the secrecy
May mean that the actors will be
portraying characters from the comics
that fans have been dying to see since
the series premiered Rosemary Dewitt's
casting as the former Mrs Campbell is
immediately exciting particularly
because it signals a coming resolution
to a disappointingly ignored plot line
though season 2's finale introduced the
absence of his mother as a key aspect of
Huey's characterization it was never
mentioned in any other meaningful
capacity during season three given that
Huey was arguably the weakest and most
reactionary character in an otherwise
decent third outing for the series
allowing him to wrestle with more than
his relationship with Starlight could
provide him with some much needed
revitalization the fact that the series
has cast such a high profile actor as to
which could also mean that season 4 will
spend a considerable amount of time on
this plotline what it could do for
Huey's characterization beside the
series might be gearing up for a
shocking reveal revolving around his
mother after all fans have long
theorized that she has a connection to
Vaught regardless this could at the very
least help make Huey a more active
dynamic character connected to one of
the show's strongest and most persistent
themes of Parenthood the fact that
Elliot Knight and Rob Benedict's roles
are being kept secret is a pretty solid
sign they'll be playing characters from
the comics likely superheroes earlier
this year the boy's Instagram account
announced the casting of Valerie Curry
and Susan Hayward as new Heroes
firecracker and sister Sage with fully
costume portraits perhaps the same as
being arranged for Knight and Benedict
down the line as to who they could play
we can only speculate the original
Comics Iron Man Batman Pastiche Tech
night has been a much requested addition
to the series having been teased a
handful of times in early episodes given
that Elliot Knight has experienced
playing an athletic spandex wearing hero
in Titans they likely won't hide him
under a bulky suit of armor it's also
worth noting that given Tech Knight
status relative to other soups he would
probably serve as The Season's big bad
which makes it more than likely that
this will be Jeffrey Dean Morgan's
mystery rule assuming that the two
actors will be playing recognizable
characters from the comics there are few
decent and realistic possibilities left
for night it's easy to see him playing
big game a parody of DC's Nightwing or
shout out DC Static Shock queer members
of a superhero team called teenage kicks
parodying Teen Titans Knight himself is
openly queer and uses the platform to
advocate for the lgbtq plus Community
queer superheroes are a rare sight in
general and giving a queer actor the
space to embody one on such a huge show
would be extremely powerful that coupled
with his work on Titans makes either
character a decent bet as for Benedict
Professor X parody John kodolkin what
helps steer the show's Universe toward
its X-Men inspired spin-off Generation V